okay
das schon lese hallo Leute hier ist
wieder eure Badewanne und willkommen zu
einem neuen nicht Adventskalender aus
Papier Video heute packen wir etwas
anderes aus und zwar eine Mystery Box
von
maskworld mit sexy Damenkostüm
halloween steht an ich will was
gruseliges machen vielen Dank an die
Person die mir das auf Instagram
geschrieben hat ich liebe
Helden und ja habe mal davon ein paar
Boxen bestellt sexy Kostüme also
wirklich alles ganz groß wird und das
sind die sexy Kostüme
easy sterben das muss die oberste Box
gewesen sein mhmm also mascord ist ein
Online Shop und auch physischer Laden in
Berlin für Kostüme Make-up alles ums
verkleiden herum was hat diese Mystery
Box gekostet schaut mal wie cool diese
Kühlboxen hier aussehen vielleicht ist
ja noch nee das ist sie also bei diesem
Deal konnte ich nicht nein sagen 19 99
statt
159 Euro darf ich dieses Jahr eine
Halloween Party mache kommt mir das sehr
gelegen dass ich ein paar extra Kostüme
habt denn auch wenn ich immer auf die
Einladung schreibe man muss verkleidet
kommen kommen die ein oder anderen ohne
Kostüm 4 Kostüme sollen hier drin sein
20 € kann man nichts falsch machen oder
gibt's den Staub gratis obendrauf mein
neues kanalkonzept ist vielleicht
einfach Vanessa packt aus warum bekomme
ich hier verlorene Koffer von Kelly
Vibes bitte stinkt nicht oh ja take a
look inside das gibt es hier es soll
Ware sein die so ein bisschen B-Ware ist
und aber noch alles zu gebrauchen okay
zuerst haben wir eine Strumpfhose wo ich
eine böse ja das ist auf jeden Fall
Zeug was schon mal anprobiert wurde ne
hier richtig Koffer weiß genau habe ich
diesmal keine Handschuhe dabei ich meine
es gibt einen Unterschied zu wurde schon
mal anprobiert Gummihandschuhe
die Box ist oh das ist echt nicht schön
also Beweisstück
okay das ist von irgendeinem Kostüm aber
dann dreht man das um und hier ist ein
Haar also mir kann niemand erzählen das
hatte doch schon jemand an
Strumpfhosen darf man noch nicht
zurückschicken hier ist noch ein Haar
seht ihr die ganzen Flusen hier drauf
also die hatte halt jemand an kümmert
sich einmal komplett über den Teppich
gerollt und dann dachte sich die Person
nee das ist sie nicht ich weiß es nicht
wenn ich eine Strumpf nee wenn ich ein
äh ich weiß ja nicht bei was für Leuten
das war aber wenn ich eine Strumpfhose
anprobiere dann ziehe ich sie an sie
wieder aus und dann glaube ich nicht
dass die so versaut ist oh das tut mir
voll leid jetzt mal ohne Witz maskworld
nimmt Strumpfhosen einfach nicht zurück
das ist ja super eklig es ist Zeit für
mein kleines dickes Notizbuch wie
notieren uns 8 € für die Strumpfhose
aber die kommt in Klammern weil die ist
ja so komisch hier ist die ist ja das
gar nicht mehr wert okay ich dachte ich
kriege hier ganze Kostüme ne als
nächstes bekomme ich ein Schild von
einem Kostüm cool ist das ein cooles
Schild Wahnsinns auch schon richtig
Pfeffer jetzt kommt jetzt wahrscheinlich
das
Rest Black Cat Kostüm da ist es der Rock
oh mein Gott ist der Kurs cute und dazu
gibt es diese bisschen zu enge Corsage
ist das die Corsage die du dazu
gehörst das eh soll das ein Halsband
sein das fällt das komplett auseinander
komische Sicherheitsnadel drin
die Ohren gibt's jetzt nicht mehr ah die
Strumpfhose gehört zum Katzenkostüm klar
das hier sind fünfteiliges Kostüm ein
Korsett Jack skirt checkt hey das ist
der Schwanz ich dachte das ist das
Halsband ach so das ist der Schwanz ein
Joker und
[Applaus]
[Musik]
okay
59,99 wenn ich die Ohren noch finde dann
freue ich mich
mann bin ich gespannt was hier noch so
drin ist
okay ein Rock wir kriegen die Auflösung
ein Top woran erinnert euch das das hier
hat Meerjungfrauen Vibes für mich die
Punkte weiß ich nicht Schilder ja let's
go ne anziehen oder auch nicht es ist
mir zu klein
hätte ich mal 10 Kilo abgenommen ich
komme immer noch dahinter was das sein
soll aber das würde ich anziehen wenn so
Meerjungfrauen irgendwas ich meine schon
interessanter Stoff nee Meerjungfrau
definitiv nicht das nächste Kostüm wird
aber mega gut oh sogar noch Schild dran
vor Playboy in Hollywood
okay einmal umziehen ich dachte das
würde mehr verdecken aber nein es ist
nur so eine Art Bolero mit coolen krank
sowas finde ich tatsächlich cool das
kann man gebrauchen für ein Kostüm um es
ein bisschen aufzupimpen ne damit kann
man viel machen ich ziehe mich jetzt
wieder um und dann schauen wir mal was
noch so drin ist wir haben wieder ein
Schild von einem Kostüm
was hoffentlich drin sein wird genauso
fühle ich mich auch
den dm-kostüme aus wie für Kinder okay
gegenfrage was habe ich erwartet ne
jetzt mal ernsthaft was habe ich
erwartet was habe ich bekommen man kann
wahrscheinlich so einiges mit so einem
Kostüm machen aber das wird mir niemals
passen müsst die eighties Diva aber es
ist ja süß er hat so sexy ist das jetzt
auch nicht wenn man da eine ordentliche
Leggings runter anzieht dann ist es
einfach ein cooles kannst auch ein
Hexenkostüm sein ja man ist voll das
Hexenkostüm eighties Steven guckt euch
diese zwei verschiedenen Wimpern an aber
was gibt's denn hier noch so zur
Accessoires Leggings gibt's noch dazu
das Kleid beinstücke manschettenkette
Gürtel Kopfbedeckung ah gibt's richtig
sogar die Strumpfhose anprobiert
also Leute wenn ihr ein Kostüm wirklich
an habt ne okay ich meine das sind süße
Extras oh eine coole Spange coole Spange
hat sich der kauf doch gelohnt das
kostet die eighties Diva oh Mensch die
EDV wird gar nicht mehr verkauft so gut
ist die machen wir mal 40 € noch unser
nächstes Kostüm Minnie Maus Mensch das
haben sie Originalverpackung reingepackt
und das ist doch schön die Ohren und das
Kleid okay pass ich da rein nee ich bin
keine m mehr das ist ja cool
Frage was ist das i verliert das viele
Haare nee nee nee nee nee nee nee das
kann ich nicht anziehen oh
hell
einspannen ist das tollste von der
ganzen Kiste und mein kleines
war das jetzt vier Kostüme 1 2 3 4 ja
faktisch gesehen waren es vier Kostüme
also lohnt sich die Mystery Box von
maskworld kommen wir zum ersten Look and
Feel die Kiste ist so staubig dass man
schwarze Finger davon bekommt
und dann wenn man aufmacht ist das erste
eine haarige staubige Strumpfhose das
hat schon mal den Geschmack in eine
bestimmte Richtung so geschoben BAM
ekelhaft
auf gar keinen Fall es fühlt sich
tatsächlich genauso an als ob ich den
einfach ihren Müll abgekauft habe ja zum
Glück habe ich das gemacht so müsst ihr
es nicht tun schön dann sehen wir uns
das nächste mal wieder dann mit einem
Adventskalender auspackt Video aber ich
sage euch mal so das wird nicht die
letzte Mystery Box sein und ich hoffe
dass ich bei der nächsten auch was
anprobieren kann ja ich weiß dass ich
was anprobieren kann denn ich habe sie
in L bestellt schlau wie ich war ne
tschüss